and we're ready to go. All right, it is the 24th day of October.
Good evening. It's a beautiful day here in Minnesota.
Sun is shining. We're supposed to get some rain this weekend and the winter is on its way
pretty soon. And the wonderful thing about living in the north, if for those who know that,
and experience that is that we have these these cold days to kill all the bugs.
So if you don't like bugs, Minnesota, Wisconsin, Iowa, these places still live because
we definitely could get rid of those sort of frost hits.
So I want to talk about people that are doing chemotherapy because we have a number of people that
are doing chemotherapy or considering doing chemotherapy and there's some things to consider
that we have discovered that can help people go through chemo much better.
So on our website, we have a resources page on the website. And on that resources page is a blog.
And on our blog, I'm posting updates on our blog constantly. So there's information on there just so
you know, if you don't get enough information, you could go to the resources page and look at our
blog on our website so you can see other articles. And there's a search feature on our blog now
so that you can search a topic. So if you type to chemo therapy in there, you'll come up with the
video that I created. And I shared it on this Facebook group many months ago. What I created
and helping people that are going through chemo and supporting those that are going through chemo.
So please search for those information. Secondly, I want to tell you that it's the burden falls
on you partly. Would you change anything? Well, you're going to decide to go through chemo.
You're going to tell us, please, we care about you. We want to know. And we might have a solution
for you. So we've had people start chemotherapy and not share that with the group. And I understand
personally, you don't have to, but you've got to share it with us because we may have some solutions to
help you go through this chemo much better. And it's proven to be helpful for a lot of people. So
make sure you keep in touch with us with any changes in your care, anything you're doing differently
so that we can help support you through that. The video that we have on that page and the supporting
document that goes with it looks something like this. This is actually a duplicate of that.
This slide presentation, this keto is a duplicate of that that's on there, but I changed it for this talk.
But we used to give just a standard sheet here, natural support for patients doing chemotherapy
with Conor's clinic. And now we are tweaking this in a word document and tweaking it individually for
each patient. So we talked to you, for instance, I just spoke to somebody earlier today that's
that's going to do chemo. Well, then we for that individual, we tweaked this word document to
give it to them. So it's very personalized to them. It's not just these two supplements that we
had them do. We had that person do one other thing. And we had we tweaked this a little bit
specifically for them. So please contact us set up a time to talk to myself or Michelle so that we
could tweak your protocol and what we want to do for you going through chemo because we found that
fasting can really help going through chemo specific supplements can really help doing some very
specific liver detox can help adding the foot bath therapy with the true right could be very helpful
and adding some other therapies that like PEMF and hypothermia and things for those who are close
to our clinic or those who are close to a clinic that may have a PEMF or have availability somewhere
near them that has some different therapies that can be very beneficial. So we want to help you the
best you can be help we want if you're going to do chemotherapy we want the chemotherapy to be as
targeted to the cancer as possible. And we want to support the rest of yourself so that you're not
poisoned as any more than you need to be from the chemotherapy. So make sure you contact us about that.
We have another question that I want to address too is if there's any changes in your symptoms
also you're going to abrupt change in your symptoms the last more than a few days because certainly
just because you have cancer doesn't mean you can't get a little bug or you can't have a cold or
you know pick up something else that you're dealing with but you're you need to communicate that
with us if you have any changes that's of course we have a lot of people that are using the Facebook
pages for that we have a lot of people that are just more intimate in their thought processes
that they don't share things on the Facebook page will make sure you communicate everything that's
going on with yourself with that. All right so a couple of other things I want to share but first
I want to open it up to questions on that so I'm going to unmute everybody. Any questions?
My question is with the fasting I'm really concerned because already very
weak is a share and I'm very weak, sluggish, lethargic as it is and I get very nauseated when I
when my stomach's empty and I worried about going 24 hours without any food or energy I'm I just
think I would be like literally you know falling apart in a basket case but yeah and that's why
we need to tweak this to be individual so for the person I spoke to this morning to very similar
situation she's already very lower weight individual and can't really afford to lose any weight and
so we had to tweak that to make it more individual to that person you still want to get the benefits
of the fasting maybe we're just going to do a 12 hour fast prior to the chemo that's
much easier to do especially if you have the chemo in the morning and that's what you might want to
request so some people have their chemo scheduled at two o'clock in the afternoon well
in the case of a situation like yours shared we may want to ask them if we could get the chemo at night
o'clock in the morning because that it's easier you could do uh still do a 15 hour fast if you
stop eating at six o'clock the night before so um and you know typically wake up in the middle of the night
to eat most people go out but um and then it would be easier to to get the chemo at night o'clock go
hold and then break your fast and start eating so would you get the same benefit as if you did a
full day fast beforehand and then fasted the day of the of the of the chemo well maybe not but
you know it could carry other side effects like feeling like you got the shakes and you're losing
weight and you don't feel good either so you have to you have to kind of kind of tailor that to each
individual and then the other question is if I mean after 48 hours I know the the most
effectiveness of the chemo has already done its work but I'm thinking if there's any trailing
benefits you know there's always trailing benefits of the chemo um the idea is you want to just
give major support to your liver detox pathways at that time um by taking uh you know
elk thistle and doing the footpaths and doing everything that we're asking you to do to help detox
your body you're not going to be pulling the chemo out of the cancer itself um you're going to
be pulling the chemo out of the rest of the body where it's not doing its job uh the chemo or
it's not doing its job on the cancer anymore because it's not there so there's there's really no
harm in my opinion that you're that you're you're limiting the benefits of the chemo by
by really supporting detox pathways after 48 hours okay that makes sense
yeah the other question yes the this chapter um is there what is how do you suggest that you best
alkaline your body so my husband read that salt and water but I think that would raise your blood
pressure. Yeah, I can't. So, um, so the best way to
alkalize your body is by, um, is by eating foods that
will that have been known historically to help bring an
alkaline, uh, bring up your pH, which are basically your
vegetables. So, juiced has been a great way to
alkalize your body by juiced fresh, uh, organic vegetables
and some fruits of apple, um, but salary, carrot, uh, beat
that the negative of juiced is if, uh, if, if your cancer
just be driven, mainly through, uh, glycolysis, your, you
are spiking your glucose levels with juiced. Um, so the
greet that's where I like the green drink, as you're not
going to get as high of glucose spike with that. Um, and so
that's your best way of alkalizing. If you have, uh, cancer in
the stomach or in the small intestine, I know people have have
used, um, baking soda, uh, a little bit of free baking soda
mixed with honey. There's some recipes on the internet. I
don't have anything on our website or blog about that. But
there's some recipes where people have, have put their cancer
and remission by mixing up baking soda and honey or baking
soda and maple syrup. I can't remember what they used. I think
the honey might be a good thing to mix it with. Um, because if
you just drink, uh, if you put a tablespoon of baking soda
in a glass of water and drink it, you know, probably throw
off pretty, it's pretty awful. Um, I've tried it before. It
doesn't taste very good. Um, what would be the amount of baking
soda? Well, it's basically the tolerance. I think the
recipe that I saw, I looked at that a couple of years ago, I
think was they put maybe two tablespoons of baking soda, maybe
equivalent to maple syrup. I think they use grade B maple
syrup because grade B maple syrup has a little more nutrients
than grade A does. But you could certainly use Meduka
honey. I think would be the same theory. And I know the
theory goes, well, you're, then you're blend your mixing it up
so that the baking soda and honey are together so that when
you eat it and absorb it, um, it will go the baking soda, you'll
draw the baking soda right to the cancer because cancer
likes that sugar of the honey or maple syrup. But in
honestly, it doesn't actually work that way because your body
doesn't absorb the baking soda, um, uh, bonded to the glucose,
you know, so you're not, that's not how it works. But it's, if
you have a cancer in the stomach or the small intestine, I
think there's some validity to that. Um, and remember, my
opinion is better, we're not measuring our pH through our
urine and our saliva. Um, you don't, you can't get an
accurate tissue pH measurement doing that. So then how do you
know if I'm alkaline or acid, you have to know that at the
site of the cancer, you're going to be acidic because the
cancer itself, be in a state of rapid replication is in a
state of high metabolism, and it's going to give off a lot of
waste, which is going to be acidic. So the cancer itself is
creating acidity. So how do you alkaline, you change your diet,
you eat better, you use the rife, rife is one of the best
ways to alkalize your body because your administrative
frequency to the cancer itself, which is a photon carried on a
wavelength. So there's going to be a dotation of an electron, which
that is by definition, if you donated an electron to, to a
molecule, you are raising the pH of it. So, um, that's one of the
best ways to, to alkalize. But I was just talking mainly
dietary, but one of the best ways to alkalize is using a rife
machine. I really believe that's one of the ways that the life
really helps a person heal. So, um, that affects your body
too. So, what about the foot bath? Um, can you increase them or
how often can you do them? So you could do a foot bath, you
could do a foot bath every day, if you want, um, the foot bath, so
the foot bath with the rife, with the true rife machine, you
could do every day. Now, there's other foot bath apparatus and
there that are called ion cleanses. And that works on a very
different principle. So the foot bath with the rife is, is just
another way to administer frequencies. The ion cleanses that are
out there, and you might have gone to a clinic that used an ion
cleanse. That is completely different. That is ionizing the
water positive or negative, and then, um, and then pulling out
the opposite ions. And that does pull a lot of electrolytes that if
you're going to do an ion cleanse foot bath every day, you
could still do that every day, but then make sure you're, you're
you're getting green straight in or you're taking an extra
mineral pill, because you don't want to just be pulling minerals
out of your body. Right. The, um, uh, the ion, I use the ion pro wave
and the, the three detox programs, and I rotate them. Yep, you're
fine with that. You could do that every day. I find with that.
Yes. Dr. Connors. Uh-huh. I was wondering about, I saw someone
is, um, looking at radiation, and, um, sometimes because of the
population of people I work with, they do get some burning and some
localized pain. So there is a cream or something to help modify
that. And then for bone pain, I recently had a patient that
used over the counter salon pause and got great relief with just
that localized hip pain from the radiation treatment. Is there
anything you could comment on about that? Do you post that on
the Facebook page? I will. Yeah, post that product on the
Facebook page. As far as the radiation bird, the skin, that is,
that is, that can be very dangerous, not just because, um, so
what's actually happening? What is radiation doing? Radiation
works because it kills things. So you radiate a cancer in a
bone and you could kill the cancer right there in the bone. But
you're going to also go through the skin and the subcutaneous
muscles and the subcutaneous fat layer and the ligaments and
everything like that. So you're doing damage to that. One of the
major side effects of post radiation of breast cancer because
with breast cancer, one of the main things they do is, okay,
we're going to do a lump back to me and radiation and, um, and
chemotherapy, uh, not in a variant, not an uncommon result is a
person getting melanoma down the road because of the bird of
the skin from the radiation. So there are some creams that you can
use. One of the creams that I like to use, we use a cream that we
make up in our office that's got curcumin in it. So the
negative is that it's got curcumin in it and it turns your skin
orange because the curcumin. But the curcumin is very healing
to, um, radiation damage tissue. So a person could also be taking
curcumin, uh, orally, but to put it right out of the skin at a
cream with a shea butter base that we use is very nice, um, but if
you're, if it's over your face or something, you're going to have a
orange spot on your cheek. But if it's over your breast or over your
over a bowed area, um, I think both of those people would
might have a little bit orange spot on their skin there from the
curcumin because it could be really healing. Absolutely. And
thank you. And I forgot to address that other question
of lizzas, whether you should do salt, um, uh, for, um, EH balance. I
know that, um, Dr. Bob Marshall used to push pig salt, um, for, uh,
different things. You do have to be careful. I'm a big fan of using a good
source of a sea salt, uh, pig salt, a Himalayan salt, because it has
other minerals in it. Um, and, um, by definition, if you add
minerals to something, you are going to raise the pH. Um, but you
also have to balance that out with, um, there is a percentage of
people and I went through this whole cardiology course a few
years ago. Um, and I can't remember what it is that, um, but it's
like 70 to 80% of the population will be reactive to salt and
will, um, blood pressure will go off. So we don't want to have
be dealing with high blood pressure at the same time.
We're getting an act of, so I hear that. So I'm going to mute everybody
and unmute them here a second. Okay.
All right. Any other questions?
Dr. Connors, um, when they tell you that your cancer is in your blood,
or has, and depositing, um, what about the use of
IV vitamin C? Uh-huh. So I think the IV vitamin C is great even if the cancer
isn't circulated in your blood. So IV vitamin C is a great therapy.
It's just one that we, and we had a couple of comments with this on the
Facebook page too, um, asking about IV vitamin C. I know some about IV
vitamin C, but since we haven't really, we've kind of been forced to not
do it in our office partly because, um, it is, um, it's, it's slightly
invasive. Now today, uh, um, as, as we talk at this time in 2018,
we'd be able to add to that to our office without any issues.
Um, and we're actually looking at possibly doing that, adding it to our office.
The problem in the past, I was so walking the gray area, especially when I had my
chiropractic license, I was dragged in front of the board.
I think 15 times and accused of everything under the sun.
And my license was threatened. Well, I was always just like, okay,
what is this next you're going to drop? And I'm going to be a jail.
So I had to be very careful, um, what I did. Now the, the atmosphere of
alternative therapy and such and what we do has, has changed.
And, um, it is, it has given us more of a creed light to be doing more
invasive things. Um, and we have slowly added more and more therapies, um,
as we can afford to add them, um, things that I would want to do.
Ivy vitamin C is one thing that, um, that is, I think it's a great addition,
is a great piece. So, um, I think it's great. And Liz, I think that's something
you should consider doing. Um, there's, there's not really a lot of downside.
You do want to get a couple of things checked in your blood. So,
whoever's doing Ivy vitamin C will want to do a blood test and check your
G6. I forgot what the test is that they want to check.
But that's the only thing that they want to do and make sure that you're safe doing it.
But I think it's a great addition for anybody. How often would you have to do it
for it to even be effective? Well, actually, there's some, there's
some new data coming out that it used to be that we thought you had to get up to
50 to 75 grams a couple of times a week. And now there's some new
information coming out that we really, you really don't need to go that high.
20 to 25 grams, a couple of times a week, um, would be fine.
And that would be a person who is, um, kind of the throws of their cancer. So,
someone who is more in a state of remission could do it just once a month.
So, um, it's not something you need to be continuing a couple of
time a week basis for, um, forever or anything like that either.
Dr. Connors, this is Deb Swartz. Um, before I came to see you, I was on high
vitamin C. And I can't remember those that she used.
But anyway, they were, I couldn't have a port. So, they were putting it in my,
elbows, my veins and the elbows. And like you said, it was invasive.
The vitamin C totally dissolved my, my veins.
It may have been the dose. I'm not sure maybe it might have been the type of
vitamin C. Can you comment on that? Yeah, it wasn't the type of vitamin C.
It certainly, uh, will, uh, the dose will affect your veins.
So, um, that's the other negative of the really, probably the only really big
negative of vitamin C is that it's a squirmic acid.
So, it's, it's hard on your veins.
If you're a bigger person like me, I probably wouldn't have any issue with it at all.
If you're smaller like you, Deb, yeah, you could have issues with it.
If you already have a port that it's super easy, it's no big deal.
You're not going to have that issue at all, but they're having,
you're having to get a stick in a vein once or twice a week.
And then you're having this IV drip.
Now, I have known people that have, have said, hey, instead of having this drip
in over an hour, can we, I'll sit in a chair for two hours and do it.
But of course, then you're dealing with just, uh, you know, the finances of the
clinic that you're going to and whether they're going to occupy that
chair for two hours and have it go in slower or be more gentle on your arteries.
But, um, those are the things you just want to talk to with the clinic that you're
going to. Um, if you have a history of having difficult to find, um, uh,
vessels for draws, for blood draws, then, then, and you don't have a port
that you may want to think otherwise, that maybe this is the best thing for you.
If you've been a person that's really easy to find your vessels and you have big
veins and you've never had a problem before, then you could try it.
Also, I will say, you can try it. And if you start to get an issue,
you can back off or decrease the frequency and allow your,
your veins to heal a little bit too. So, um, but, um, so again, it goes back to everybody's
different and you're going to have to see if it works for you.
You said 20 to 25 grams. How would you say, did I?
Well, uh, most IV clinics right now start you at 20 to 25 grams
and their goal is to get up to 75. So, um, but I just, um,
uh, heard someone speak who does this all the time.
He said that he had, uh, a bunch of data where it showed that 20 to 25 grams,
you don't really need to go beyond it. There really isn't any added benefit
beyond that. So that was his opinion. Um, uh, and, uh, so that was
interesting information. Uh, so, you know, and if you have to look at your body weight
and such too, so you have to take that into consideration.
Okay, thank you. Any other questions?
I guess I have one more. Um, how about ozone in your vein?
I, IV ozone. So IV ozone can be really beneficial to
I see IV ozone more beneficial for possibly lying patients.
Um, then for cancer patients, though I know some practitioners who think
ozone is good for cancer as well. Um, we had some patients do ozone
as well at their cancer. And, um, I was very optimistic that that was
going to help and it didn't seem to help at all. So I'm more than
willing to try anything, um, that isn't harmful for a patient.
And my, my, um, judgment of that is when I do that myself,
if I wouldn't do it myself, I, I guess I wouldn't, I would try it on one
of my patients, but if that's not invasive, it's not has no
downsides, if it's worth, uh, and there's some data that it could help,
I certainly am not against trying something. Um,
doing IV ozone, there's really, there's very little
harm at it. Um, you know, there's any possibility with anything you do, but I
don't think, you know, the chance of harm at that is,
here is zero. So it's certainly worth a try. Um, I'm just trying to think,
wrap my head around, um, the mechanism of action on it, but, um, I think it,
I think if anything, the what IV ozone could be good for us to decrease
inflammation, or that could be beneficial, um, all around too. So, um, I think it was,
well, for me, between the IV biomancy and the ozone, it
brought my circulating tumor down, because that would take
kept testing. Make sure that, make sure that, does that make sense?
I have not heard any data on that, but that's possible.
Okay, thank you. Dr. Connors, this is the chapter. I have a,
I have a porch. So, um, so would that be really easy for you?
Right. And, but is there any problem with having, being, being on a chemo? I,
I'll be taking chemo, uh, a different type of chemo, uh, once every month.
Okay. So, so in the, in the old days, you, you just say, if you're going to do a chemo, a chemo is
an oxidative agent. That's what a chemo is. It's a poison. So,
poisons are oxidative agents. That's how they work. You give a person enough poison,
oxidizes their cells, they stop working and you, you know, sell not working, you die.
Um, and, uh, and vitamin C is an antioxidant. So, one of the things that you say to a person is,
if you're going to be doing chemotherapy, well, don't be doing, don't be doing vitamin C at the same
time. You're kind of, you're kind of doing two opposite polar things here. You're giving a whole
bunch of antioxidants at the same time as you're using oxidants. Um, but what, what they're finding
and what the current belief system is, is that high dose vitamin C is, is oxidizing. It's not an
antioxidant. So, the, at least the current belief is that you could do high dose vitamin C while
doing chemotherapy. You're not negating the effect of the chemotherapy. Um, however, your
oncologist, right, living in kind of old world thought pattern there. And I don't want to say,
I didn't mean to say that in a negative way, but maybe they keep it back, you know, a few years ago,
where it's a, it's an antioxidant and he would probably be adamantly against you doing vitamin C
because of that. And if you're, if it truly isn't antioxidant, then you would, would agree with him
because while we're trying to poison you with an oxidant, we don't want you to unpoise it yourself
with vitamin C. Um, but the current light of thinking is the way, the reason why high dose vitamin C
works is it, it's, it's basically an oxidizing agent. So, um, there's, I don't know how much
supportive data is out there on research. So I can't, I can't point you to anything without doing
a Google search myself on that. But that's at least the current line of thought with that. Um, you
may want to know that by your oncologist and see what he has to say about that.
Right. That's where my, it was too. But thank you for addressing that because, you know, you, you want to,
you want to do as much as you can do to stop the cancer, but you don't want to kill yourself in the mean
time. Right. Exactly. That's exactly right. Thank you. Uh-huh. Absolutely. All right. So I am going to end our
call here. And I am going to make another video, um, uh, soon just to give you an update about me,
you know, just for those who want to know what I bleed and what's going on with me physically.
Um, if you don't show what I'm talking about, then you can watch that video. I'll post it
in the next week or so up on the Facebook page. And I can be helpful to some people going through the
path that they're going. So that's what we want is to all be supporting each other through this, through this
journey. Any other questions before we sign off for the day. Dr. Connors, I have one more advocacy thing
to share. Um, I've been, I had an appeal made to get increased chiropractic visits. And it was
denied, of course, as experimental and experimental in some other crazy word. So I called the insurance
company about the appeals process because people often accept that's the end of the line. That's not true.
The chiropractor can, well, I drafted the letter for him and did the research. So the chiropractor is
going to be city, um, submitting a rebuttal letter and a reconsideration letter to the insurance company.
And when they denied that, then there can be a doctor to doctor consult done with the insurance
company's doctor, which I think he will do fabulous with that level. But just don't stop with
the first denial is my, um, is my input to that. I'm pretty sure that the insurance adjusters only have
one rubber stamp and it says denial. So it's, uh, it's kind of a game they play and it's, they just don't
want to pay for anything that they don't have to pay for it. They pick the low hay fruit, which
is alternative care. So that's correct. Where the situation or in. So. But of course, I'm a little
persistent and I'm not giving up with the first denial. That's good. And it's, if nothing else, make
their life a little miserable. Maybe they'll learn a lesson from it. And that's what I hope and to
help because kind of practice is generally denied after you reach whatever your policy.
Authorizations are so, um, anyway, because I get lots of benefit because I get a pulse every time I'm
there too weekly, which makes a world of difference. Absolutely. That's great. And so anyway,
that's just a bit of advocacy for ourselves. Well, thank you so much.
Dr. Rogers, this is Lisa. I'm not going to take any more time, but I, I wanted to thank you very much.
And I haven't researched it myself yet, but I wanted to sometime have you talk about stem cell.
Uh-huh. Yeah, I just read a book on stem cells just this weekend.
So yeah, maybe next Zoom call address stem cells and
possible stem cell use with cancer. Um, a number of my colleagues are doing stem cell currently,
just in brief, stem cell therapy is, so we're talking about benzene kind of stem cells that are
typically, um, they're from, uh, uh, sent out or a medical cord blood. So there's not really any
use for fetal stem cells. That affects fetal stem cells. Though there is this huge giant
scream about it several years ago, remember, um, fetal stem cells cause cancer in people. So fetal
stem cells are completely undifferentiated and have no stop mechanism. And you know, there was people
screaming and and lobbying, Congress and everything for use of fetal stem cells. All the fetal stem
cell clinics have closed down, um, even overseas because everybody that they use the fetal stem cells
and develop tumors. Um, they just have no stop mechanism because um, fetal tissue is supposed to be
constantly replicating. A billical cord stem cells are the way to go for stem cell therapy.
Today, a billical store cord stem cells tend to be undifferentiated enough so it doesn't stimulate
any muter spots, um, by the person you're injecting the stem cells in. And it has stop mechanism,
so it doesn't, they don't form tumors. However, the real benefit of, uh, a billical cord stem cells
are in the field of orthopedics. So you have a bad knee and you're scheduled to get knee
replaced with surgery by, by statement to you would be stop right now, go and get um, stem cell
injection in your knee. Um, I have, uh, maybe 50 colleagues that are doing this right now that, uh,
were in by functional neurology, um, online function, our functional neurology board. Now they're
all in the stem cell therapy. And the results are phenomenal, like at 90% of the cases people do not
have to have replacement. So with joint issues, hip issues, um, uh, even muscle issues, orthopedic
conditions, it works fantastic. Um, they're even using it in muscle issues with, uh, people with
muscular dystrophy. There's, uh, new experiment patient going on with use in, um, uh, late stage
line patients. Um, uh, there's some cases with line patients that are real bad that, uh, are using it
individually, uh, with some good results. And that brings a lot of hope to our line patients that
we have out there. It's not being used right now really with cancer patients. And, uh, but there's a
lot of information that's available that we could talk about. I, I will tell you, I just have that
hip replacement in August. And it, um, it's been wonderful to be without pain. But I think
the hip replacement, that major surgery like that, set my cancer, all the inflammation that had to do
with it could have set my cancer on fire. Well, it can't because how do you heal from a surgery? You
heal from a wound. If you cut your hand, so if you take a knife and you cut your hand right now, um,
normally your, your skin cells regenerate. Um, I can't remember. I take good skin cells every six
weeks. You're epithelial of your skin. But if I cut my hand right there and I have to wait six weeks
for those skin cells to regenerate, I will bleed out and die. So when you have a wound, surgery,
a cut, an injury, your body sends out growth factors. So your IGF-1 levels go through the roof in order
to heal that wound so that you could bring scar tissue to that area, that you could, that you could,
that bleeding could stop and you could heal that wound if you could wound over and scar over and heal.
So your M-tore pathway is up-regulated. Remember what M-tore is? That's your growth pathway. So your
growth pathway is highly up-regulated. So depending upon how bad damage is, so if I cut myself with
a knife a little bit of a cut, I hardly bleed and I put a little bandaid on it, we're not going to
really have much of an up-tick of my M-tore pathway. But if I do make my surgery, I'm going to have a huge
up-tick of my M-tore pathway. Well, that's not going to be discriminatory to that wound site. It's going
to be through out my body and that can increase the cancer growth. That's why I've said multiple times,
multiple places that I've not a big band of breast augmentation and reconstructive surgery
post mastectomy, because you just got a debulking of that tuber with the breast removed
and allowed that to heal. Well, that in itself was a surgery which up-ticked M-tore. Now you're
going to do another surgery and I understand I don't have breasts and I am not one that I have the
right to come at and whether what a woman feels like not having a breast. But there is, you have
to realize the risk of that other surgery, it's going to increase up to her. So there's just those
issues. And you know, if I do what I do now Liz talking to you a few months ago, I would have said go
and do the stem cell injections into that hip and give that a chance before you do the surgery,
we don't know. Maybe it wouldn't have worked. But we just got to-
I might already destroy it by prolonging it, you know, for eight years. Eight years ago,
I should have asked the stem cell. Thank you very much for- this new cell was a wealth of
information in a lot of different places. Very beneficial. Oh, that's great. Does the
stem cell work on your shoulder like a load of cuff? Absolutely, yep. Oh, great. Okay, thank you.
Yeah, works phenomenal for orthopedic conditions. When for bone cancer? No. Okay. All right, well,
thank you very much and we will talk very soon. Keep posted on Facebook and we'll get your
answers as we know how and always remember, we don't know everything. So sometimes the answers
could be, I don't know, or I'll have to figure that out. So I appreciate you guys so much. We appreciate
the prayers that you give our clinic and for everybody here and we cherish those more. So we'll be
praying for you and continuing this battle that we're all in. All right, bye-bye. Thank you.